we're now entering into 1944 where the
Americans and the Allies are able to go
even more on the offensive versus the
Japanese and get closer and closer to
Japan get in bombing range of Japan and
and and deprive the Japanese of I guess
you could say their forward bases and so
right as we enter into 1944 and once
again I'm giving you an overview I'm not
giving every single battle that occurs
the United States is able to take
Kwajalein which once again the strategic
value of a lot of these a lot of these
at these islands are tiny they're barely
large enough to have a kind of a
primitive basis plus kind of an airfield
but they're incredibly valuable because
the Bombers can land refuel or get
resupplied and then take off from there
and then get beyond the offensive either
further in even further in I guess you
could say Japanese territory and with
the ticking of Kwajalein just as a bit
of a reminder the Americans amongst
other things now had control of the
Solomon Islands they now have control of
the Marshall and Gilbert Islands they
now have control of the Marshall and
Gilbert Islands and as we'll see the
real theme of 1944 as we get into the
middle of and the end of the year is to
get as close as possible to the Japanese
mainland because the Americans now had a
b-29 or they had the b-29 bomber that
had a 1500 mile radius 1,500 mile I
guess I could say 1500 mile range which
means if they're able to get points of
where where their bombers could land and
take off and once again these bombers
are way too large and heavy to land on a
carrier but if they can find Islands
where they can do that from within a
1500 mile range of Japan then the United
States could have bombing attacks
directly on on Japan and hopefully get
closer to an end to the war so that was
really the theme get as close as
possible to Japan and then there was a
secondary theme of taking back the
Philippines one it was a matter of pride
it was a former US possession ever since
the Spanish and Spanish American War but
then on top of that the Philippines are
incredibly strategic for shipping lanes
from Indonesia remember
those raw materials those resources that
oil that Japan wanted from Indonesia if
you control Japan if you control the
Philippines you're going to control the
shipping lanes between Indonesia and
Japan so you could deprive Japan of
those natural resources so the United
States kind of main focal areas in 1944
get as close as possible to Japan get
within bombing range and take the
Philippines and this is exactly what
they did as we go into the summer of
1944 and one there were there were some
as early as the summer of 1944 some
bombing raids that took off in China to
Japan with the new b-29s so you do have
some of these that happen as early some
of these bombing raids happen as early
as summer of 1944 but in terms of actual
islands or territory the United States
takes or takes back in the summer in
June of 1944 you have the Battle of the
Philippine Sea
so Battle of Philippine Sea occurs right
around right around here it's a victory
for the u.s. it's a victory for the US
and it ends up really really I guess you
could say hurting Japanese ability to
field carriers have have air warfare
from carriers because they saw so much
of their the carrier capability was
damaged in the Battle of Philippine Sea
so the battle the Battle of Philippine
Philippine or maybe Battle of the
Philippine Battle of the Philippine Sea
this occurs in June June 1944 and along
with that in the summer the the Allies
are able to take take several islands in
the Mariana Islands that once again this
is going to be super important because
from the Marianas they're able to launch
b-29 bombing attacks on the mainland in
Japan and so over that summer the Allies
the Americans in particular are able to
take
I pan they are able to take they're able
to take Guam they're able to take Tinian
which is this little island right over
here some of these islands are quite
hard to find there they're super small
in fact even these little dots
exaggerate their size if you were
actually going on Google Maps or Google
Earth you'll see how small these aren't
I encourage you to look at them it's
really fascinating to see how small some
of these islands are there really atolls
a lot of these are are more tools than
islands not all of them are tools but
you see that there they barely have
enough space for a landing strip for
planes especially the b-29s and then as
we go further into this summer and we
start entering kind of later in the year
the Americans are able to take at the
time it was called palely now it's Palau
so palely you they're able to take more
Thai they're able to take more Thai and
then perhaps most importantly in 1944
this might be the the biggest deal out
of all of these Pacific battles that
occur in all of these naval battles that
occur is the Battle of Leyte and the
Battle of Leyte Gulf because the Battle
of Leyte was important is because in the
process of taking Leyte the United
States essentially is able to knock out
the Japanese's ability to further defend
I mean they will continue but
realistically defend the rest of the
Philippines
so once Leyte is taken by the Allies
it's the the odds of the Japanese being
able to hold the rest of the Philippines
becomes very low and maybe even more
important the Battle of Leyte Gulf which
recurs right around there it's an
incredibly decisive battle for the
American Navy the Japanese go all-in and
that bet is not a good one the Japanese
Navy is pretty much destroyed in the
Battle of Leyte Gulf and so 1944 once
again very good year for the Allies very
bad year for the Japanese now the Allies
are in control of they're in control of
air strips from which they can take b-29
raids to the mainland of Japan
whoops so air strips they can now
they're now within range to do bombing
attacks on the mainland of Japan and
they now are very likely to control the
Philippines which will and control the
shipping lanes from Indonesia to Japan
and they've all but destroyed the
Japanese Navy so once again things are
not looking very good for Japan and as
we go into 1945 we'll see the the Allies
get closer and closer and and get more
intense bombing raids on Japan and every
time they get closer the battles to take
these islands
Iwo Jima Okinawa incredibly incredibly
bloody and the United States says well
what do we have to do to get the
Japanese to surrender and we'll see what
at least in the mind of Truman needs to
happen